it's Halloween season ghoul so crawl out
of that tomb of years and put on your
best funeral Tire because we're gonna go
over some of the best horror games on
game pass to scream and crawl your way
through right now
first up is the all-new survival horror
signalus this is a Sci-Fi Cosmic horror
where you play as a robotic being known
as a replica named elster who awakens
from cryostasis on a wrecked ship
stranded it alone as Ulster you have to
navigate nightmare scenarios while
solving puzzles unlocking new areas and
traversing a dilapidated ship stranded
on a cold and desolate Planet borrowing
from the roots of the survival horror
genre you'll have to carefully manage
resources while also fending for your
life from Silent Hill like monstrosities
personally I love that signalus captures
inspiration from the PS1 Dreamcast era
of survival horror while maintaining its
own distinct visual style and identity
that it makes it appear as something
more than just a nostalgic rehash after
all survival horror is back in fashion
with remakes and refreshes coming around
every single corner from Silent Hill to
alone in the dark and Resident Evil 4
which by the way we have Hands-On
coverage from yours truly so make sure
to check out the card order if you're
interested in that oh and I nearly
forgot about another big old remake on
the way Dead Space which brings us to
the next on our list
sure Dead Space is a 14 year old game
but like a true classic it stands the
test of time exceptionally well
especially when it comes to its scares
regardless if you've played this roller
coaster of a horror Fest or not now is a
good time to revisit it with its remake
on the horizon based on our video
preview by Jean-Luc seipke it's managed
to make him a veteran fan of the series
still very excited with that in mind it
sounds like it'll be following the same
beats as the original but changes are
being made to freshen things up
including giving the game's protagonist
Isaac Clark a voice there are fuel the
centrifuge is offline who in the
original was completely silent until
they gave him a voice in Dead Space 2
but until we can play the Remake one
thing is for sure the original Dead
Space is still terrifying in fact we
have a whole video breaking down why it
scares are so effective card in the
corner remake aside Game Pass ultimate
also has Dead Space 2 which like the
first all holds up so damn well and in
the chance the second Dead Space gets
the same treatment as the first with a
remake it'll likely be a while until
that happens so you know in the meantime
you could you know just play Dead Space
2 you know the the original one as for
Dead Space Three uh well
um I don't know depending on who you ask
you know there might be a difference of
opinion on whether or not you should
play it I'm not going to tell you what
you shouldn't do but hey no harm in just
loading it up as it is also on Game Pass
just you know don't expect the same
horror of the first two just keep in
mind that dead space is only included
with Game Pass ultimate which gives you
access to EA play if you have a standard
Game Pass subscription EA plays in a
part of that so you know
okay let's take a break from the space
horror no horror game list is complete
without the seminal classic amnesia the
Dark Descent and its sequel Amnesia a
Machine For Pigs now these games need
little introduction and are yes maybe
oldies for some of you but they are new
however to the Game Pass roster so this
may be your first opportunity to jump in
unless you know maybe you've already
bought them but you haven't been able to
finish them because you might think
they're a little too scary so you play
with the lights on and even then you
still can't deal with the scares so you
go to a public place like a coffee shop
and play it there but then you scream in
public uh when you're being chased by a
fleshy sack person with Limbs and then
you know I'm clearly not talking about
myself uh really but seriously these
games torment me I fully admit here and
now that I haven't finished the first
but I've tried many many times because I
do really love the story the puzzles and
the grimacing atmosphere but holy hot
damn they are very effective at messing
with you nonetheless the first Amnesia
is emblematic of spawning an entire
subgenre of horror games leaving the
player entirely powerless and having to
run and hide from the monster rather
than fight it nowadays that just sounds
like a Mainstay Trope in several games
like Outlast and layers of fear but a
lot of that DNA is owed to the original
Amnesia not to mention the entire era
that spawned YouTuber Let's Plays of
that game amnesia the Dark Descent isn't
just a pivotal moment for the genre but
online gaming culture too
while we're on the topic of frictional
games the developers of the first
Amnesia we of course have to include
Soma this one isn't in space or any
sultry dungeons but in the depth of the
ocean which to me is one of the most
terrifying places I can imagine being
trapped in Soma you play as one of the
last standing members in the pathos 2 an
isolated underwater facility containing
AI controlled Machinery things have gone
a bit re to say the least and now you
have to seek out its last remaining
inhabitants amidst gruesome creatures
maniacal machines and the omnipresent AI
That's intertwined into all the facility
systems this like the Studio's previous
title is about avoiding and outsmarting
the enemy as you're totally helpless
against them but unlike Amnesia however
which featured Inventory management like
having oil for your Lantern and Sanity
pills SoMo focuses more heavily on
narrative putting more emphasis on
stealth and puzzle solving
here's a game that isn't in space or not
even underwater in fact it's more like a
fleshy nightmare than anything else
scorn is a disgusting lambrinthian
trudge the contorted gruesome goopy
walls of an HR Geiger inspired world it
is a skin-wrapped mystery where you're
put in the body of an unnamed
protagonist who suddenly wakes up in an
alien-like World controlled by bodily
technology everything is made of Flesh
Bones skin and guts and I mean
everything the Machinery the
environments even the guns and really
that's all the game gives you it's just
a matter of maneuvering the world
learning the strange Tech solving obtuse
puzzles and fending off these cute
little fleshy Pals it's also quite a
slow burn emphasizing its world and
environments over everything else and
all of this is punctuated with the lack
of any tutorials directions or narration
you are very much dropped into this
breathing Nightmare and just have to
find your way out of it this game isn't
overtly scary in the ways the others are
on this list instead it just oozes is
with an overtly graphic tone of Gore and
violence and that is enough to solidify
it on this list
[Music]
The Evil Within series I'm putting both
of them on this list because I think
they each serve an interesting place in
the realm of modern horror games with a
second really taking some daring
Liberties and expanding the foundation
of the First's mechanics as a series
it's over the top and convoluted in a
story that goes to some rather
Fantastical links like entering unreal
worlds and navigating a diverse set of
locations while taking on monstrous foes
and some really creative and terrifying
enemies it really leans hard into the
survival aspect favoring stealthy
scenarios picking off baddies while
Gathering supplies to in turn craft
traps or ammunition admittedly I think
these games are just okay but I applaud
them for being an over-the-top horror
romp and their creative monster designs
the second one especially takes it a
step further by bringing the survival
into more open-ended sandbox
environments it's also got some really
beautiful set pieces but still very very
spooky ones campiness aside The Evil
Within is a must play for horror fans
and there were plenty of scenes that
still managed to make me crunch the
controller in my hand as I navigated
claustrophobic Halls while out running
scary beasts
[Music]
alright friends thanks for cozing up to
this campfire list of horror stories I
hope something here jumps out at you so
turn the lights out grab yourself in a
blanket and enjoy the frights happy
Halloween